um well listen the man sued me once and
lost
and then he appealed and lost that also
i don't know what the matter would
why didn't call this child john or what
jane or whatever
hi i'm jeremy clarkson hello i'm james
may hello i'm richard hammond and
i'm going to be answering the lad bible
questions the fans questions the fans
questions
is that right uh-oh which of you three
is the best driver and why
it depends how you define best driver i
mean if you come out of a pub and you're
wasted and
um and you want to get home smoothly
without being sick i would say james may
is the best driver
if you want to get around a racetrack as
quickly as possible then that would be
me
and if you want to know what it's like
in the back of an air ambulance it would
be
richard hammond i'd be me yeah i'm
pretty confident that both the other two
will agree they'll have to but it's me
we can rule richard hammond there
because
sort of 20 of the time he ends up on the
roof uh
jeremy is better than me at driving
round the track you
would want me driving if i if you were
being taken to your wedding or
a state occasion who is the most famous
person in your phone book
i don't know you have to start at prince
harry and work your way down to david
beck and we'll go the other way around
boring but i'm going to have to say it's
either jeremy clarkson or richard
hammond because they are pretty famous
those two
james may he's i think he's only got six
friends and they're all librarians
that's really dismal isn't it what a
failure all these opportunities and
that's the best i can do
and they're not even in there under
their own names how did you save their
names
one one is world's biggest and the other
is world's smallest so you can probably
work out what the other way is
of the three of you who is the hardest
to travel with
i'll be honest i mean jeremy's you know
bloody annoying
uh
jeremy well i suppose i mean i'm
fairly hard in airports because i can't
see why you can't just get on the plane
and it takes off
i want to start an airline call i take
my chances there
so what if there's no security checks
nothing just arrive at the other
car pulls up at the plane steps you get
on and yeah and
if it blows up well it blows up if you
catch kobe you catch covered if it lands
at the wrong airport you'll land at the
wrong
airport it's listen i'll take my chances
there are you guys a fan of elon musk
um well this and the man sued me once at
lost
and then he appealed and lost that also
i don't know what the matter would
why didn't you call this child john or
jane or whatever uh yes overall i find
elon musk very interesting and i have
one of his cars i can see why he winds
some people up and
some people think his business practices
are nefarious but i don't really
understand this and so i don't know if
they are or not
i just see a bloke with interesting
ideas having a joint
i like elon musk i think he belongs in
like a comic
i think he's a sort of superhero made
real
the world needs people like that with
huge amounts of money doing crazy things
who is the worst dressed on tour
i mean it's just we're all home because
i mean i stopped buying clothes in 1978
james may gets dressed under the kitchen
sink
out of whatever we can find down there
oh and james is worse dressed
not just three of us but pretty much
anybody
trust that's a really true it's me isn't
it that's what you it is me
i'm the worst dress which celebrity
would you most like to add to the grand
tour presenting team
i mean you know i could sit and say i'd
love to have kristen scott thomas along
for the ride or
charlie strong or someone of that nature
i think angelina jolie can bring a lot
of
insight to it um i just like to
talk to her about cars and stuff but the
truth of the matter is
three guys who know each other well
respond well to
what the others are saying i think
that's a fairly good formula and i
wouldn't really want to change it
um
mary beard and in one of these like
just high intense moments i was like
i'll have your babies and he looked down
in my direction and did like his little
paolo nutini smirk and i was like
[Music]
i could die a happy woman
[Laughter]